I don't want to see a woman that I I
think is quite attractive come out of a
toilet let's go I give it a minute if I
were you yeah I've absolutely left the
steamer back
and also I have to say I I also I mean
this is a personal preference but I
don't want to I don't want to hear yeah
an attractive woman yeah taking the next
door no I don't no no one wants that
yeah no that's not true there are a few
people who do
uh Steve Milburn uh
get your flat cap on lad uh what's our
thoughts on the gender neutral toilet at
Waterloo Station good for a cue jump
I don't mind playing ones with cubicles
where everyone can go to their own thing
yeah that's fine but I did once use the
toilet I've told the story before and it
was [__] horrible it was actually at
the Battle of ideas believe it or not
when it was still at the Barbie and I
walked in it was a toilet with a urinal
I was standing there yeah of course
doing the business and everyone just
walked in yeah
and just walked continued to walk in I
didn't have the decency to run out
pretending screaming yeah going oh my
God it's massive yeah there's no way I
could fit that
anyway yeah I was standing there with my
Charles Dickens out yeah right yeah and
she just like went oh did she have great
expectations
oh anyway I don't think she did after
what she saw anyway
and it was uncomfortable for both of us
exactly
is my point right now why do I have to
pee with a woman watching
put you off your stroke if anything I
mean strzok is the wrong choice of words
yeah it does yeah it's not natural yeah
I'm nostalgic yeah for the days when we
had toilets for different Sexes you know
the two Sexes yeah I look even at GB
news they've got gender-neutral toilets
and I've got be lot and there's cubicles
in it whatever I don't like it I don't
know I don't have a problem with the
cubicle what's your issue with the
cubicle I just don't I like there to be
a bit of [__] mystery mate
I don't want to see a woman that I I
think is quite attractive come out of a
toilet let's go I give it a minute if I
were you yeah I've absolutely left a
steam about that
and also I have to say I I also I mean
this is a personal preference but I
don't want to I don't want to hear yeah
an attractive woman yeah taking a [__]
next door no I don't no no one wants
that yeah no that's not true there are a
few people who do
there's a few people on the internet
yeah who'd pay a lot of money for that
right
www.shitteachers.com all right
Francis what two four no no that is way
too far no it's not too far because that
is a legitimate website my mate showed
me when I was 17 years old and I got
PTSD as a result thanks then says you're
not living with a woman are you well of
course I am right yeah I prefer she does
it outside like a lady
keep yourself romance happening
look I'll be honest with you ladies we
don't want to know that you like we want
to think flowers come out of your eyes
exactly
that's what we want to think yeah right
yeah
we don't want to be disabused of this
myth you're supposed to be perfect it's
supposed to be beautiful you're supposed
to smell nice yeah
you don't want to see a beautiful
Bridget bardos woman walk out the cue
balls because and go
you don't want a waspy to be going past
that cubicle and then it [__] dies
yeah
I don't want to be that wasp either yeah
nobody wants her let's keep romance
alive do you know why Romeo fancy Juliet
because he didn't see her on the [__]
you probably did back in those days I
think it was a lot more rudimentary
anyway anyway let's catch up on the
super chance Francis